it's a thursday edition of pro football
talk live nbcsn series xm211 sky sports
this drew brees emanuel sanders a little
pitch and catch
more responsible than what we saw in
tampa this is akin to what we saw from
russell wilson and dk metcalf if you're
gonna do it this is the way to do it
long distances in between player and
receiver now still it's another
quarterback it's another receiver it's
another team defying the nflpa
recommendation to do none of these
things until it's time to go to training
camp but if some teams are going to do
it then all teams need to do it because
if you're sitting home
constantly repeating to yourself the
recommendations of dr tom mayer
reminding yourself that's why you're not
out working out with teammates and other
teams are doing it you're at a
disadvantage that gets back to our point
from yesterday why it's it's just not a
good idea to flaunt it if you're doing
it but they're doing it they're
flaunting it not like brady did and i
think it's going to continue chris
during the three weeks that we'll be off
and after we return in that week or two
before training camps open on july 28th
we're going to continue to see videos
and stories about guys
doing what the nflpa has asked them not
to do
well yes i mean the nflpa told them not
to do that but you know kind of like i
said yesterday i think drew brees and
tom brady first off you know these are
ocd type a perfectionist we know they're
gonna work out and throw footballs and
do all those things but you're also
seeing that you know hey their brand is
every bit as important to them here too
they're gonna put it out on their social
media and show that they're doing the
work and yeah kind of a big fu to the
nflpa but you know mike to your point i
mean yeah if you're a quarterback and
you're sitting at home right now and
you're going oh the nfl pa told us not
to get together and do any workouts and
things like that
yeah well all i can tell you is it's
nice you're listening to them but the
other quarterbacks and especially the
top quarterbacks in football will not be
at home doing that so you're going to
start losing the competitive advantage
and i have a hard time thinking
that there won't be more true gatherings
you know like we've seen uh with tom
brady at the tampa bay buccaneers you
know kyler murray like you said it seems
like they still kind of had their
workout last weekend but went off the
radar it didn't show anybody which is
smart
i would hope that would be the thing
going forward but you know you are
seeing these quarterbacks they want to
prove to everybody they're doing their
work too mike and i don't know why they
feel like they need to do that other
than their brand and get followers and
likes and all that kind of crap which is
stupid to me
yeah like i said yesterday with tom
brady the smart play is go do your work
and not let other quarterbacks know let
them think that everyone is sitting at
home
not working out with teammates and then
that's how you gain your advantage and
preserve your advantage because
everybody else is doing exactly what
you're doing you're not getting that
same edge that you otherwise would get
it's that simple but it's vanity it's
ego it's
selling your tb12 brand your lifestyle
everything that goes along with having
the exposure the notoriety and it
overcomes i think common sense and it
overcomes proper behavior in a pandemic
and look
before we veer
too far in the direction
of things that will upset people just
the mere fact that we even have to stop
and say oh we may veer in the direction
of things that may upset people
the idea that there are
just look around
that's all i'm going to say pay
attention to some of the things that are
out there like videos from bizarre
city council meetings in florida the
beliefs that people actually have the
fights we're having the the warped
viewpoint of what it means to wear a
mask i mean i'm gonna eat stop right
there but just the fact that it's
controversial why is it controversial
why why is
practicing
smart hygiene and care and safety in a
pandemic
why is that even controversial chris
anyway anyway this kind of stuff only
takes this twilight zone existence that
we currently have and makes it more
twilight zoney
yeah i mean i understand you you know i
mean you're right well
listen the country's confused there's a
lot of mixed messages as we know i'm not
trying to be a jerk here or getting
anything like you know super critical
either but there's a confusion
the fact that we're tiptoeing
illustrates how screwed up it is right
now doesn't it there's a confused
message especially when it comes to the
pandemic and the virus coming right from
the top we know that i mean yes there's
no other way to say that and that's why
you're seeing some of the states that
listen to every word our president says
they're starting to see rise in covet 19
cases so yeah i mean i understand the
confusion from the society because our
government i'm sorry has led us all to
be confused i mean there's no other way
i see that so i don't care i'm not
tiptoeing in there i'm jumping all in
splash um so you know but we'll see but
i you know again i think we're seeing go
ahead what do you want to say go ahead
well
well
here's an example
and and maybe we shouldn't tiptoe maybe
more people need to be the grown-ups in
the room if people are going to scurry
around spewing all sorts of nonsense and
behaving in a way that is completely
contrary to how we should be behaving in
this moment because folks again look
around it's getting worse
it's not getting better it's getting
worse yesterday the highest number of
positive cases yet
in our country period and if you want
something tangible and of course this
becomes a chicken and the egg thing
because some are going to say oh they're
acting out of fear and others are going
to say well they're acting out of common
sense hall of fame game cancelled hall
of fame game
cancelled according to shefty the hall
of fame enshrinement ceremony postponed
indefinitely why why because of the
pandemic because of what's happening
because people are applying common sense
because people are being smart because
people are realizing yes there's a
problem here and and uh
again this is
it there will still be people who look
at this and sneer and say it's fear porn
are you kidding me chris yeah they can
you know they can say what they want but
you know until you get some of these
fears okay taken care of which is a
consistent good message from the leaders
of our country to steer us all in the
same direction there's going to be no
football there's going to be no sports
the economy is going to stink and that's
going to be because of the lack of
direction that is leading us to the
right you know pathway in our country
that's they're simple you know we talked
yesterday about england and the premier
league and why they're doing so well you
know and i should have came into that
more informed as far as exactly why
they're doing so well well when the show
got over what did i do i started looking
ups up and reading stuff and oh wait
that's right well they've been very
strict and been very good with their
pandemic rules and how they've handled
it in their cases and their their
testing per person is way up the cases
they have in their countries are way
down and like you said we're going the
exact opposite direction again we're
still we're we're back in the middle of
march here in america which is not an
encouraging thing and you know it's
going to hurt the the prospects of the
nfl being played this year which i also
think is very ironic because you know
we're going to be hurt by it because of
the lack of leadership in our country
starting at the top and it's also ironic
because we have a lot of owners and
people who supported him in the nfl and
now they're going to get bite in the
butt because of it
strange juxtaposition though when you
consider some of the events that have
happened this week where you see a lot
of people congregating a lot of people
not wearing masks you try to put that up
against the numbers that keep coming out
and it's impossible to reconcile the two
and it's hard to reconcile chris the
report that there will be no hall of
fame game this year with yesterday's
report for me and rappaport of nfl media
who works for the nfl so when something
like this comes from him safe to assume
that it's accurate
training camps still set to open july
28th teams are still
targeting july 28 to be there and okay
and and and i'm going to try to help
people understand how we can reconcile
those two
it's one thing to have all of the teams
show up for what will be
their
their universe
for a month right the place they're
going to be every day a controlled
environment that's one thing it's quite
another to take two teams
out of their controlled environments
drop them into ohio
for it a couple of days at hotels there
and around ohio and all the stuff that
would otherwise go on with the hall of
fame weekend take those two teams drop
them in
and then put them back no
you get them in where they're going to
be and you leave them there that makes
so much more sense the whole idea of any
neutral site game this year other than
the super bowl makes no sense right you
keep
teams and players in a tightly
controlled environment as long as you
possibly can that especially early on
while they're trying to figure out how
this is all going to go the last thing
you want to do is have a neutral sight
game to start your season so
it's i think that it's not as dire
as that first reaction would be that oh
god here we go here we go there goes the
hall of fame game what's next weeks one
week one of the preseason what's next
all the preseason what's next week one
of the regular season i don't think it's
that dire i just think that for a game
that means nothing
nothing at all
yeah for a game that is just for a game
that is just part of the entertainment
part of the experience for hall of fame
weekend you don't want to bring two
teams into that environment you want to
leave those teams in their environment
is going to be carefully set up and
structured chris for training camp and
then uh yeah obviously
you're going to be bringing teams into
separate environments
who are the you know the visiting teams
during the season but that's different
and that's necessary this isn't the hall
of fame game is not necessary yeah get
rid of all un unnecessary things that
you got to do in this you know training
camp whatever it may be i mean yeah
there's no point in risking any of that
um and you know mike to something you
were saying you're right i mean i think
the nfl the nflpa the players everybody
involved
i do think you know
the start of training camp will start
july 28th all those things i i do i i
we've seen some of the game plan the nfl
has as far as testing people you know
the tiers in which are allowed in the
building how many people are allowed in
the building the facility how close they
are to be together you know i know the
nfl is going to do everything they can
to make the environment safe i'm not
worried about that necessarily but you
know i'm worried about again
you know these nfl players it's
different year your training camp it's
not training camp where we've seen in
years past where you go to some college
or you go to a hotel
and you're all there
and you you don't see much outside life
and it's just football and back to your
hotel and meetings and football and back
to your hotel and meetings
now there is going to be going home
because you know from the way i
understand it at least right now it
doesn't sound like anybody is staying in
the facility to sleep there or staying
in a hotel but the the thing that i
worry about mike is not necessarily the
players it's just like okay hey here's a
guy playing in the nfl you know his wife
and kids went to the country club today
or went to the local park and you know
they've been swimming in the pool or you
know in a place where there is a little
bit more public contact now those
players are going to go home see their
family and here we are in day 14 of the
training camp it's running rampant
through some team because of that and
that's where i just don't know where
this whole thing goes and you know
that's where i get back to where i just
would like a better gauge of where the
nfl players feel about this if they were
to go ramp it through their locker room
but here's the thing the players that
are old enough to have families then
that have households and have kids that
are at the age where they're out doing
things right
there needs to be responsibility within
those households and they need to
understand you can't go to the pool
there's certain things you can't do now
at some point they're going to be going
to school
presumably and that's a different issue
but you know this is just part of the
challenge that is going to trickle down
from the organizations to the players to
their families if we want to have a
football season and i think events like
pulling the plug on the hall of fame
game will get people to take this
seriously if they aren't already a
couple of other items related to this
there was a report yesterday that the
nfl will be tarping off the first six to
eight rows at all stadiums which implies
that the other rows will be available
potentially for fans more on that in a
second there's gonna be advertising on
those first six to eight rows and look i
think it makes sense to have that buffer
zone that splash zone right you don't
want fans who may be infected close
enough to the field where they could
throw stuff onto the field where just
the droplets if they're coughing if
they're yelling if they're screaming
those droplets go out and they hover
over the sideline makes sense to take
those first six to eight rows out of
play makes sense to turn those tarps
into dollars and cents
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports